I've been testing these acquire smart
home devices and they have blown my mind
because they are not only the easiest to
set up but by far the most feature Rich
now about a month ago I was watching a
video doorbell comparison and I thought
to myself man I wish I had one of these
because of the quality and the features
and then a choir reached out to us
wanting to sponsor a video showcasing
their lineup and of course I said yes I
would love to check it out but what I
didn't expect is that the whole system
worked well and that the Smart Lock
would be so amazing way better than the
two major brands that I have bought
previously now here I also have their
g2h Pro Camera which is also a hub for
zigbee that connects the devices
together like this door and window
sensor now what is really cool and
unique is that these work not not only
with the acquire app which I will show
you guys but they also work with home
kit and you can actually set these up
using home kit only and then your
footage from the doorbell will record to
your iCloud and apple is giving
unlimited storage and it is all
completely secure and encrypted so
nobody else can see that but you now I
have another home kit device but
unfortunately if you set that up with
home kit it only works as a home kit and
I couldn't use the app and that means
that you can't unlock all the features
whereas this can work both with homekit
and with the app as well and the setup
was incredibly easy now I will kind of
split up this video into the features
what comes with it the setup how the
performance goes and then the acquire
app the door and window sensors are
incredibly small way smaller than I've
seen with other brands and they come
with a battery that is in there and that
thing lasts for two years the camera Hub
is also very small for the quality and
the features in the Box you get a bottom
mounting plate that attaches to it and
built into the camera you have this
stand that tilts and Spins and kind of
extends the camera which is cool and
then on the bottom you can actually put
in a Micro SD card in there to record
locally which is really cool now with
that one thing that is really cool is
that you don't have to sign up for a
plan to get recording even if you don't
use home kit you get free storage not
only on the SD card but also for in the
cloud with aquara app and then you can
upgrade to get extra features but that
is nice to see where most companies now
are forcing you to pay unless you just
want to see a live view this thing has
infrared for night time has a wide
single lens supports homekit secure
video that's encrypted you have two-way
audio motion and sound alerts as well so
it has a lot of stuff packed in and then
with that you also get if this then that
support built into it along with of
course the zigbee protocol which is
universal now with the video doorbell
this thing is super cool for many
reasons first off it comes with a chime
my camera to buy for 180 bucks and then
I'd spend another 40 bucks for a chime
and this one actually has a Micro SD
card slot built in as well they support
up to 512 gigs of storage so you can
record locally along with your home kit
iCloud storage and the acquire app
storage so that is super cool it also
has on-device AI facial recognition and
logging so if you care about privacy you
don't want your facial data and
unlocking being sent to the cloud being
processed and coming back well this has
that built in and with that you can
actually stream video to both Google
home devices with the display or Alexa
devices like Alexa TVs now I think what
my favorite product out of all these is
the Smart Lock I spent 330 bucks on my
recent Smart Lock and this thing
destroys it and I'm shocked at how low
the price tag is for how well it works
and how well it is built this thing is
incredibly solid everything you get is
super high quality with it I'm just
ecstatic about these products now with
that the video doorbell is also a very
very well priced surprisingly well
priced for the quality and features less
expensive and a lot better along with
the sensors and the camera as well I'll
go ahead and leave the links down in the
description for you guys to check out
now in the Box a Smart Lock comes with
batteries just like the video doorbell
does you also get two high quality keys
and some tools and accessories to set it
up now I think it's really cool that the
Smart Lock and the video doorbell use
double a batteries because you can get
those anywhere you can use regular
alkaline ones or you can use
rechargeable ones without having to have
proprietary expensive batteries that you
have to unplug plug into charge or get a
base or buy extras to swap out so that
part of it is very convenient and on the
Smart Lock they last for eight months
the video doorbell lasts for four months
if you don't have it connected to your
physical doorbell power which I didn't
set mine up that way because it's way
off to the side and to swap it out it's
very simple you literally have one screw
on the doorbell pop off the top and swap
them and then on the Smart Lock you
literally pop off that cover and pull
them out put new ones in so that part is
not an issue at all getting into setup
if you're worried about doing these kind
of things aquarium makes it easy because
they literally have videos that will
show you what you need to do now
starting out with the camera it was
super easy I grabbed it uh plugged it in
and I set it up with home kit which just
guides you through using Apple now with
the smart doorbell it's also not hard at
all you have a couple plates you have
one that's an angled adjustment which is
what I used and then you go ahead and
you scan the chime it pairs it and it
pairs it to the doorbell itself so it is
super easy now as far as a door sensor I
put that on my slide door and I didn't
have to do anything with batteries I
just pulled a little Tab and I paired it
to the hub and then the cool thing is it
guides you through a set of process and
the way I set mine up is that when the
slide door opens I use the automation
then where it will record a video clip
from the camera that way if somebody
gets into my house well the camera
automatically starts recording and then
of course it gives me a notification I
was really surprised by how quick I got
that notification on my phone and how
quick with little delay
um the camera started recording and my
slider has a thick frame so I was
worried that it was a little too offset
but it worked perfectly and that manual
says you can actually have a gap and
have it still work as long as it's not
too far away so you don't have to worry
about that now setting up the Smart Lock
is the most detailed because you have to
take off your original one and then you
have to have a couple different pieces
they give you different length the bolts
but if you follow the guide it's really
easy it should only take you about 10
minutes or so to set up and then you can
link it using the back of the cover to
your home kit now I set everything up
with home kit and that works great and I
love the fact that when you open your
home app you see the video doorbell and
then you see the interior camera and it
can actually put them both together so
you have a quick view at what is going
on and with that if you're using home
kit well if you have any other Apple
devices your Mac your iPad that all gets
done automatically and you can see that
feed now you can set up automations and
go through the settings with home kids
but then if you want to set up the
acquire app which I did after the fact
it was really cool that when I opened up
the app and I registered well I got
pop-ups right away saying that it saw my
video doorbell and do I want to bind it
so literally just takes a couple buttons
bam it is set up you don't have to go
through the whole process again same
thing for the other devices I was also
really impressed with the video quality
with the internal camera I was spinning
around looking at the delay and it is
literally about a one second or even
short delay compared to some of my other
cameras and then speaking with my son
through the two-way audio we had no
issues hearing each other now as far as
the video doorbell well the quality
compared to my other doorbell is crazy
uh not only just the main quality but
right away the quality looks fantastic
whereas my other camera at first it's
low resolution then it gets sharper and
sharper but even with the best quality
it is a lot worse than the aquaras the
1080p so don't only think that 1080p on
two devices means the quality is gonna
be the same it is definitely not and
another few things that impress me is
that when somebody comes up and hits
your doorbell not only will you get your
notifications on different devices you
get the chime notification that goes off
and the camera with the speaker built-in
also goes off so if you have them spread
out throughout your house well you will
hear that because it's pretty much
everywhere wherever you want it and that
is nice and if if you haven't linked as
soon as you open the video doorbell you
have an unlock button that you can press
to unlock your Smart Lock now with that
the response time was also really really
great about half the time to get a video
signal compared to my previous setup
that I had from a major brand and now I
want to focus a little bit more on the
Smart Lock which is amazing I love that
as homekit built in so I can just open
up that home app but with that this
thing has so many ways to get into your
house first off I love that you can just
walk up to your house and if you have it
enabled it will just automatically
unlock and if you leave it will lock up
but if you don't want to use that
functionality you can walk up and with
your iPhone use your home kit Express
key and in about a second your door
unlocks and the same thing with your
Apple watch you can just put it up you
it will unlock your door now if you
don't want to do that it has a
fingerprint sensor built in so you can
walk up touch it it unlocks your door
very easy and then if your hands are
dirty or something else well you can use
the the little keypad to enter in your
passcode now the cool thing is that you
can actually set up different passcodes
for different people so I 7 up with
myself I can set one up for my kids and
that way I'll get a notification that
you know my son for example put the key
in or use a fingerprint and he is home
and a lot of that kind of stuff is
locked but with that since it has this
keypad you can actually create one-time
use passcodes to give to somebody that
needs to get into your house or you can
set up temporary ones that will expire
after a certain period of time so it is
so nice to have that built in compared
to something else that only relies on
your phone now if your batteries are
dead you can actually plug in a USBC
power cord say power bank and you will
have backup power to unlock your home
and then if you don't want to do that
well just slide down the little metal
flap or cover and just use your standard
key to get into your house so you pretty
much have every single possible way to
unlock your house built into one device
that costs about half of what I paid for
my way worse one and then the other
thing that impressed me in this probably
a long video now I but the time that it
takes to unlock the door is about half
of my other option that I had that was
double the price tag so as soon as you
press it less than a second later bam it
is unlocked super responsive and I also
have not gotten any jams using this
compared to my other system which would
jam up and then you'd have to try
multiple times or in the worst case
scenario have somebody actually go up
and unlock it and that doesn't work if
you're not home now I want to show you
guys the app and some of the things that
you can do so here I have the home kit
setup which I did first here I can
actually go ahead and set up access
codes guest access right from home kit
so you don't have to use the acquire app
personally I really do like the app and
all the extra capabilities and the way
they have it set up so let's take a look
here's the home page and then here I
just see all my accessories instead of
my board you have automation set up
right now I just have one thing that
I've done and that is the slide door
record and the way this works is it's
literally if this and that kind of like
the protocol people use but it's built
in so if somebody opens a slide door
then it sends me a push notification and
starts recording and it is incredibly
fast to do that now of course we can add
extra things and this is just so
powerful to be able to do this so we
have based on time weather you can
arrive or leave but let's go ahead and
open up our smart video doorbell so here
we have lots of options but let's just
go ahead and say known face Max I have
that set up so if that happens then what
should we do we can set a notification a
delay we can set up scenes so with other
devices you can have lights that turn on
or turn off music if you want to do
certain things there's so much
capabilities that I just can't cover
unless this video is gonna be an hour
long you have your home kit setting here
where you can see the devices you can
synchronize names here's your linking to
third-party ecosystems so actually
linked to Alexa so I can use Alexa to
you know lock the door to unlock all
those kind of cool things and then of
course you have all your different
settings there's so much to fine tune
but the nice thing is if you don't want
to mess with a lot of fine details
you're not into that well you don't have
to you could just leave it in easy mode
with home kit and here's the page for
the Smart Lock right now we're not
connected by bluetooth because I'm not
there but we have lots of everything
that was done events different alerts if
that was there I can do user management
so here I have one fingerprint and I
could even set up a one-time password
like I told you guys before now going
into our smart video doorbell bam that
is connected and I can manually go
between different qualities or set Auto
and then you can hit record to record or
you don't have to you can talk you can
see different events so this was the
mailman right there dropping off a
package you can turn on lens correction
adjust your night vision you can set
privacy areas as well which is really
cool I had your watermarks there are
just so many features built into these
devices but with that it's simple to use
even here I access everything very
quickly without having to go through
menus and find particular things so
using these has been really nice to have
more flexibility more options home kit
has been amazing and the fact that the
price tag is so so good and then the
Privacy feature is local storage I've
said it all if you guys are interested
go and check it out I would highly
recommend getting an acquire a set
instead of some other competing Brands
which I will not mention you guys could
do some of your own research too like I
was doing previously links are down
below thank you to a choir for reaching
out definitely appreciate it this is Max
and I will see you guys in the next
video